there's like this tone i've seen in some
of the media coverage
where it's like hey some jerks want to
reopen schools
and then the media organizations are
like
casting that as uh
a terrible idea and dangerous
and then as usual the truth lies
somewhere in between
um so first can we lay out the case why
frankly kids actually benefit from
school or need school
like schools are are like a huge
value-add on
several levels yeah i mean i think that
there's there's a sort of kid case and
the kind of economy case for why we have
schools and so i think on the on the
kids side um
one clear thing is that kids learn
better in school so we saw this
you know we i mean that should be sort
of obvious um but even if you sort of if
you look for a data from the spring
about kind of what happened to
metrics of learning uh when kids went
remote
you know they they went down a lot uh
kids do not learn as well
uh as well remotely and that is
particularly true for students who have
fewer resources
uh and so that i mean the the kind of
potential learning losses and the
inequality in those learning losses if
we
you know if we are fully online or
with kind of no yeah as we were in the
spring the potential losses for the year
are very are very significant so i think
there's just like huge value for kids
and being in school
and it isn't just learning it's also
socialization you know sort of thinking
about like what is your five-year-old
getting
out of out of school yeah part of it is
like they're learning to read they're
learning their letters but part of it is
that they're learning to like operate in
the
operate in the world um we don't know
that much about what's going to happen
if we lose those things but i think we
have a sense that
that they're that they're important and
then there's a sort of separate issue
which is just
schools are the kind of childcare that a
lot of people are using
so if we want people to be able to go to
their jobs and
you know participate in the economy
particularly women we need to figure out
something for their kids to be
doing during the day and if that's not
school i don't know what it's
uh what it's going to be but you know i
think people have bristled this idea
that like school is child care like oh
well school is not child care well
school is definitely child care people
always travel no it is i mean
it's not a pejorative it's not it's not
meant to be pejorative but it is it is a
thing that people are
using for child care for sure and i
think it's important to recognize that
yeah you know at this extreme end my
wife evelyn
said something because she's always
looking out for um for kids she said
like schools are an abuse detector where
if if you are
um uh mistreating your child like the
most
common place people are gonna pick up on
it is when that kid goes to school and
that they have like a bruise or marking
or they seem traumatized uh so you know
like
it's it's child care yes i mean that's
just a factual
uh reality but it's also in some cases
even like a safeguard or a haven and
it's a place people
get food right i mean sort of look at
like what you know what happened to food
insecurity over the last
uh you know over this this last period
you know many many more kids who are
going hungry because
you know the school lunch program is
serving you know millions
tens of millions of kids every every day
and and i think part of what's missing
from some of these conversations is a
lot of the people
having these conversations are are it's
not they don't care about these issues
but they're not living them
right so we're having this conversation
and like the truth is like if my kids
don't go to school that is going to be
annoying for me
but it is it is not you know there is
there is nothing existential
it's not it's not exercise right exactly
and a lot of the people who are having
these conversations are in that role and
so we're sort of like it's hard to
really visualize
quite how bad this may turn out to be
for
kids who are in a very different
situation
so let's see if we can try and define
the impact of an extended summer slump
because i know when kids go off for the
summer and they're they're not
doing a whole lot um that there's some
data around
the fact they forget stuff uh the fact
that they learn things so let's say we
extended the summer slump
by several months for the spring which
we probably did uh like do we have any
sense of
of how and as a parent um my kids
haven't learned [ __ ]
for like quite some time you know it's
like
like they they you have online school
but like
i mean it's not great and uh like
and anyone who's out there first
actually let's unpack that for a moment
because there are
a lot of um like techno optimists
who are like hey um online school
is the future online school the bomb why
do we even send kids to school
like online is the way do we have data
on that aside from my anecdotal
um sense uh that my kids have not been
exactly
like uh you know tearing the world up
over the last number of months
i mean i think the best data i've seen
on this was put out by um actually one
of my colleagues who's at opportunity
insights
and they use data from cern which is an
online math platform that's linked to
eureka so it's actually a platform a lot
of schools use
um so it's basically so eureka is like a
standard math curriculum and then cern
is this like
like online portal where you basically
like kids can sort of self learn
in in zurin a lot of schools use it in
school
and what's really nice about it is you
can track progress really granularly
because there's like these badges so you
can see like at the end of each lesson
like you do this activity and then you
earn a badge
so you can see like how quickly are kids
learning these earning these badges
uh and so they they look at sort of what
happens to kids who are enrolled in
schools who are using cern so the school
is using zern before and after
and they can see like what happens to
the number of badges
and in you know schools in high income
districts the
there is some learning laws that share
you know the like
badge earning goes down by like i don't
know 30 percent
uh or something in in schools in
low-income districts and this isn't
low-income kids it's just schools in
low-income districts so
it's going down by about 70 oh my gosh
like yeah so it's basically like people
and now some people have said well
like maybe people are you know have
moved to other i mean this sort of like
technological like
and maybe people move to even better
systems for remote learning
i think my view would be like it seems
like the easiest thing to transition
would be an online math
platform that you are already using if
you ask like what is the thing that is
going to be the most successful of
moving to remote learning it would be
things that are already on the computer
and so i think that that you know that
gives you a sense i mean if you kind of
translate that up to the whole
year i mean this is like a like an
unbelievably large amount of
learning loss beyond the summer slump
which is already there
yes so so it sounds like if you had to
just throw in
a couple numbers out you could be like
look um
these kids are learning math uh at 30 to
70 percent
less efficient or slower rates uh than
had been the case when they were in
in-person schools as like a just a
general
estimate which jives with my sense of
reality like if you were to tell me hey
their learning is slowing up by
thirty to seventy percent um i would
agree
uh and what what you said about uh the
social operating system that kids get in
school so i was a very nerdy kid
and so i think that's mainly what i got
out of school was trying to
like traffic on like what the heck is
going on why is this kid um
you know seem to be mad at me or
whatever like uh you know like
that kind of interaction um and for my
kids too
like when they're online learning uh
it's really
you know they're not learning that and
they just like wander off i can actually
sense my kids becoming less
uh with it or personable because they're
just not forced to interact with a whole
lot of other people
and i'm sure parents around the country
are experiencing the same thing
yeah i mean i think that people's you
know it's sort of been been
interesting in a negative way for many
of us to kind of realize the ways that
our kids
deal with this which is mostly not good
um but you know there are sort of kids
like who are super social for whom i
think this has been like obviously very
like hard you know it's sort of like
just very hard they're
moody they're angry they're you know
they're depressed like they just can't
can't see people and then i think there
are other kids um i think at least one
of my kids a little bit more like this
and maybe this is one of yours where on
the one hand
actually seems fine like they seem
pretty happy but you can sort of
see that there are things about
interacting with other people that
they're starting to like
their like skills at doing are starting
to decay yeah
right and then you know when my kids
went back to camp it's actually like i
did and they were around other kids i
realized how much they had missed that
and how much you know for my
five-year-old like like re-engaging with
the question of like okay what is an
appropriate amount of wrestling
to do with another kid uh you know and
like how am i supposed to like for him
sort of like monitoring his behavior is
is a thing like all five-year-old boys
like we we work on i realized we'd sort
of like
not had any of that um and i think that
you know that is a big piece of it was a
big piece for me of learning in school
um like how do i deal with other people
thank you for listening in i hope you
enjoyed this conversation
if you did please do subscribe to yang
speaks and click on notifications so we
can let you know
every time we have a new episode
you